within the last few hours military
vehicles including tanks have been seen
on the outskirts of donetsk the capital
of one of the breakaway regions of
eastern ukraine
in an address on state tv in moscow last
night president putin announced that he
was recognizing the breakaway regions as
independent states
our security and defense editor deborah
haynes joining us now live from the
ukrainian capital of kiev um hello to
you uh deborah good morning um is this
be how is this being viewed in ukraine
today
with fear and concern events yesterday
unfolded so quickly you'll remember it
started with hopes of of diplomacy led
by france's president and ended like you
said with tanks rolling into separatist
held parts of ukraine after the russian
president having convened the national
security council which was broadcast on
television this incredible theater
deciding that he was going to recognize
these two breakaway regions that have
been under the control of russia-backed
separatists for the past eight years
effectively shredding eight years of
diplomatic efforts to try to resolve
this crisis through negotiation turning
his back on what's known as the minsk
accords and putting his troops into that
territory saying that they're there as
peacekeepers and building on this false
narrative that has been generated over
the past few days in particular that the
ukrainian government poses a threat to
civilians living in that area that's
simply not true say the ukrainian
government but despite that we saw those
images didn't we of civilians being
evacuated out of the separatist held
parts of luhansk and donetsk over the
last few days and now these russian
forces supposedly peacekeepers moving in
all of this watched on in horror by the
rest of the country and the big concern
being that should russia accuse ukraine
of launching shells against its troops
in that area even if that's not true
then that could be the trigger for a
wide scale invasion